[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream number
83 q and a's session with
all kinds of madness yup you're right
yeah there's a certain amount of you
know
yeah it's cute all right we have
so many amazing questions this time um
even even more so than usual i already
feel bad about all the great questions
we won't get through so let's just
let's just do it the cats are in the
sink snapped ineffectively there we go
yeah
okay um is there any
i'm good okay we start with three
questions from last time
go to our discord question and then jump
into some of the many questions from
this time that are so good
is there any benefit to being raised by
biological parents
as opposed to adoptive genetically
unrelated parents
um yeah you you want to
i'm ready you go first okay um
in one way a simple yes the simple yes
is
that the pattern is especially in
households in which you have a mixed
brood between adopted
and and genetic children
there is a difference in things like uh
injuries abuse all sorts of things so
that's probably reflective of a deeper
pattern
and so yes that is that that is not to
say though that adoption doesn't work
perfectly well
um uh especially in circumstances that
that um
that foster its functioning so um it's
not an absolute answer
but yes statistically speaking that bias
exists
yeah i guess i would um there there's
there's a lot to say here
um what you said is true
anecdotally i grew up in a family of
that description
in which i was the genetic child of of
my parents and
my brother you know the four of us
lived together and and uh we're you know
we're oh we were away my brother and i
always told we looked like brother and
sister
um but he was adopted and i was not um
and
um the research evidence is a match for
my anecdotal evidence that um
even though there were all attempts made
to treat us completely equally it was it
just didn't
happen um and that
is that has been observed across across
situations that said
uh entirely genetic brewed families and
entirely non-genetic brewed families
might well not have differences between
them and i don't i haven't seen the
research there but i would predict that
that parents who are loving who have you
know one or two or three kids
none of whom are their genetic kin
would likely not suffer in those
families would not be in any way
compromised
by the fact that those children were not
their genetic cancer yeah and precisely
because sorry
precisely because um is you know one of
the main premises of our book
which um i guess we'll talk about
whenever our next live stream is because
it's in chapter one
is that we are we are so much more
software than hardware
humans are we have at the point that we
are born there is so much yet to be
decided and discovered about who each of
us is going to be
um that that that that part of us that
is determined
by our genetics is just far less
important relatively speaking in a human
than it is
even in a chimp or a wolf and certainly
than in a
you know a sponge or a cedar tree
[Music]
um as also the case that adoption is
probably wired into
our software at the very least in a very
ancient way absolutely there would have
been lots of adoption of
relatives on loss of a parent or
something like that yeah
and there's adoption in other species as
well other primate species
yeah not not stranger adoption right
right right stranger adoption is novel
but the point if
software is there it can be co-opted and
it is also the case
that when a family adopts they're making
a very deliberate
choice and so yeah you know there's the
possibility you don't happen into
adopting a child right you don't adopt a
child by accident yeah yeah
and so you you might therefore predict
uh that such families
would be more loving you know more you
know more able to
be fully present with their children
how much credence should be placed in
gert vandenbosch's objection to
ivermectin as a prophylactic
this again a question from last week and
i don't remember
enough about you know it was a long time
ago it's not that long ago but it feels
like a long time ago
that you had the conversation uh with
there's been a lot of bad arguments
since yeah and i don't know if he still
feels the same way he did nor do i know
exactly what right i don't remember
actually so i i can't answer it okay but
i
i should know um and i wanted to check
back in with him anyway
yeah um this is an interesting moment so
i will do this
well it's certainly an interesting
moment it's a very interesting moment
yeah
uh yes yes true um
what is your take on the political
platform at neil for
democraticpresident.com that is i'm
plugging a platform i've worked on the
last three or four years that i think is
right up your alley and you might find
interesting
so i asked you well i was sorting all of
these to take a quick look over the
break
i looked at it and so uh neil number
four democrat
neil for democraticpresident.com um
so forgive me neil if that is in fact
your name
uh i hope i will not butcher in having
just briefly perused your site your
intent but it seems to me
that what he has done is kind of create
a placeholder where he's going to kind
of
run for the office that he doesn't want
and doesn't intend to take
in order to hand it off to somebody who
might be more suited to the job
because he's not particularly ego driven
and he lays out some
some useful tools for thinking about
political stuff
and problem solving and and things like
that and so
um i think he's a very dangerous person
oh really very dangerous yes i haven't
seen it but i can see on your face that
i should be concerned
well i i'm sort of speaking for the
powers that be
right that's cool you know somebody like
that
who's just kind of trying to do the
right thing because somebody needs to do
it and dare he
yeah well i mean geez if everybody
started acting like that you know
where would it be then right i mean how
would they distribute their garbage
narratives and
yeah how would we sell them [ __ ] how
would we sell them [ __ ] and make them do
things and
cow them into submission and all of the
other stuff so
why don't we cow people into submission
rather than shaping them anticipation
yeah or bowl them into submissions no
why do we cow them and not shape them we
talked about differently
um no
because it's it's the action so that's
why you would bull them because the bull
could maneuver you into
into you know a quadrant of the pastor
you didn't why don't we wolf them into
submission
because we're too busy wolfing them down
i don't know i don't make this stuff up
i just respond to it
okay from the discord this week there
were two questions
and uh we're going with the second one
why do bees keep putting up with us
stealing their [ __ ]
what do they gain from being kept by us
are we in a mutually beneficial
relationship with bees or have we just
enslaved them
oh you so totally nailed it right there
like one statement before the last
statement they always do
yeah they always do yeah yeah the dis
the discord day
the discord day yeah like all of the
other critters that you
want to feel terrible for because you
think it's like a wild animal that
you've plucked out of its life and
inflicted death on we
are in a partner relationship that is
spectacularly
good for all of the creatures that we
have partnered
that we have long partnered with i would
not make this argument
at all for the poor creatures who are
captured for exotic foods
uh or something like this but
and in fact you make a strong argument
against just that
in your unheard peace yep it is it is
there and i strongly believe this
as much as i don't think this had
anything to do with the bush meat trade
or
the exotic animal trade other pandemics
have
other pandemics have well almost
certainly one hiv
hiv but these things are barbaric in
their own right
these trades and they do put us at
greater danger
than the other kinds of contact that you
might
might have with the with wild creatures
but anyway the point is keeping
beekeeping not so much beekeeping oh bee
bee keeping is good for bees well i mean
it's an interesting moment to be asking
this right like there's another part of
human enterprise that is destroying bees
which we all know right like you know
and
it's not it's not universally agreed
upon what is happening to the bees but
it almost certainly at least one big
piece of the puzzle
is the uh insecticides things like and
glyphosate mm-hmm
um so um that has nothing to do with
beekeepers though
right so the point is the ancient
relationship with bees or the
semi-ancient relationship with bees well
the huds
they don't keep bees do that the hadza
the hudson eat honey but they
smoke them out and yeah they still honey
but they don't have a relationship with
bees right
but the raising of bees is certainly
positive for bees and in fact in north
america
our bees are asian uh imports
um which is certainly good for them we
transported them across a gap we humans
transported them across a gap they could
not have covered
so anyway yeah there's lots positive
from the bees perspective you could say
the same thing
for chickens sheep goats cows everything
else
but the point is nothing says this is
permanently a great relationship and
things get
very different when you start factory
farming and
things like that so what i would say is
there is a healthy relationship we
shouldn't feel
bad about having given these creatures
such a great deal
but we actually have there's a there's a
contract
a moral contract between us and the
creatures that we house and
we damn well better live up to it yeah
all right on to questions from this week
dear hmb could you please do a
systematic analysis or series of pods or
video
for each cited piece of ivermectin
evidence in the flcc
sees review pdf we need your rational
articulate analysis
in a form that can be circulated and
discussed worldwide thank you
i don't know so this was this was one of
the top
monetary value questions which
occasionally i won't read them because
they're just obnoxious and this wasn't
obnoxious
um i don't know if we'll do that
um we've done some things very
systematically and carefully
and um there's a lot of moving things
right now
and i just i'm i'm not sure but i
appreciate hearing the
the request yeah i would say directly
there's a
there's a cost benefit analysis what is
the best use of our time and i will say
it's not you know i would love for
someone else to be doing that sort of
like you know
i i always wanted great textbooks yeah
and well
there's a lot of reasons that i didn't
use textbooks one of them is that i
don't like handing people pre-digested
pap
but there was literally one book aside
from lab manuals when i was teaching
comparative anatomy
um that was nominally a textbook that i
would ever consider giving to students
and that was
priyanka's evolutionary ecology terrific
terrific book
most textbooks are garbage and it's a
really tough job you know it's a giant
target it's a moving target the research
is changing all the time
but i really i always hoped for some
other people who were great at what they
were doing to really want to do that job
and this is the sort of thing that um
you know it's sort of
more more in my skill set than yours-ish
but i also don't think it's my highest
and best use
um so no it's not and
you know i think you know i think hey
look we've won
on lab league at least the first layer
yeah well this is this is an ivor
macdonald i know but my point is lab
leak actually
describes the proper way that this works
um you know there was a division of
labor in the
fight over the lab league yeah and the
people who were
excellent at that other thing did it um
and in this case
you got a bit of a different situation
because uh you especially i think
you and i together are very good at
analyzing these things and you're very
good at
sorting the detail of exactly you know
methodologically what happened for
example but
um but god damn there's a lot of
failure and yeah we could become
ivermectin all the time and we could
justify it because it's a very you know
because lives are at stake but it's not
the only place and so
well it's it's different
the story isn't as technically
complicated
right because it's not a question of an
evolution
and a potentially enhancing of evolution
and you know in all the bits of the
virus and
and how it's interacting with the body
and the various systems in the body and
all of that which is
just an amazing sort of scientific and
detective story with regard to the
origin
the what is the origin story of ceresco
v2
um whereas ivermectin is a story um
which
is emerging from clinicians and from
countries
and so um you know you're left with
having to you know just receive data
that you hope are good
and then assess how those data are
analyzed
and you know i'm when i used to teach
statistics
i was very careful to teach the simplest
possible because i hated the idea of
people
having spent all this time generating
you know observing a pattern generating
hypotheses
creating experimental design collecting
the data and then shoving that into some
black box
of a statistical analysis that they had
no control over and
then spit them out a number and they're
like i guess the computer says yes their
computer says no
so i don't know i don't trust
and i don't know how to assess nor do i
believe that most of the people who
claim to know how to assess
fully the very complicated statistical
analyses that are being done for the
most part
with these sort of meta-analyses um
actually know what they're doing
and um and i don't claim to know
i can get a few levels in but i don't i
don't i can't go all the way to baseline
right with these analyses all right i
now know what i think the answer this
question is
okay it makes no sense to do this and
the reason it makes no sense to do this
is that there's probably a ton to be
said about the quality of those studies
about their defects about the
implication for their results but the
evidence is
so far beyond what is necessary to apply
a
safe drug to an ongoing pandemic yeah
that the point is
yeah you don't need that you're asking
for precision when you've got enough
accuracy to tell you to go
yeah no i think that's why um
that's why i just like cleaned up the
slides and like we're gonna show these
slides
like we're gonna we're gonna just show
these and it rests on the idea that the
data are what the data claim to be
yeah but other than that there's nothing
you like you come to your own
conclusions
look at you know these these those
slides that we showed in the first hour
today
um simply have you know if the data are
what the data are claiming to be
here's case counts here's fatality
counts uh before
and after the introduction of ivermectin
widespread
across five different countries and in
one of those countries across four
different states
and you can look at what happened uh in
states that did have hypermectin
and what happened in a state that didn't
yeah and
come to your own conclusions i guess um
but
i don't know how to look at those graphs
i i don't actually i would like to hear
what the the people who are saying
there's no evidence you know
you know where are your crts um what
they say in response to those and we're
not claiming that those are
hypothesis tests right but they you know
one after another after another after
another and
clinicians saying you know what i'm just
doing it wait a second they are
hypothesis tests they are not hypothesis
tests in the classic
sense the fact is every new country
or every new province that applies
ivermectin to a wave of covid
is a test of the hypothesis that
ivermectin effectively treats
covered patients and prevents new
infections period yeah
okay so uh yeah the first
the first time anyone does it on their
own not having
thought not having seen data from
elsewhere it's an observation
and it's a bunch of convergences um but
presumably
at least let's just take the most
obvious example within india
unless all of those uh whatever they're
called chief ministers
um did it on the same day simultaneously
they
you know began to look and went like oh
actually i'm gonna do what that guy did
yep yeah yep good
canada has announced that for those who
received the first dose of the
astrazeneca vaccine the second dose can
be either the astrazeneca or the pfizer
or moderna vaccine have you any thoughts
on the logic to this
ps thank you both for keeping us sane
last year
i think i think we talked about this
yeah
i think last q a the short answer is you
would love to know
what the combinatorics are but basically
there's nothing wrong with the logic
that says this should work
but what we do know is that the
expectations of how these vaccines work
do not match what actually happens in
the body
well in both cases so astrazeneca is dna
right so astrazeneca and jnj are dna and
physical
mrna but they're both using the spike
protein they're both you know basically
coding for the spike protein
that is then supposed to stick on the
outside of your cells that your body is
then supposed to recognize and then
um become immune to covid should you run
into it
and um so if that was all as clean as it
sounds like it should work
but the you know the problem is that the
spike protein doesn't seem to be
sticking to the cells and it's floating
circulating widely and spike protein
itself is a toxic menace yeah
so uh the basic point is
the vaccines do not work the way the
brochure that
describes them says they should it's
possible that they do in some people and
don't in others but it is clear that
there is an awful lot of leakage of
spike
protein that is supposed to stick in the
cell surface and in light of that
are you better off with two different
you know there might be slightly
different failure modes of the different
vaccines maybe
um you know but yeah so maybe it's
actually better
but you know those trials certainly
haven't been done right yeah
uh yeah you can draw your own
conclusions but there's nothing
fundamentally wrong with the idea of
mixing between the vaccines because the
whole point is you're informing your
immune system with spike protein and
a different mechanism that gets you
there could be positive
it could be negative it's probably not
wildly different
but it could be that's a possibility too
yep
is your opinion of insect repellent
fabrics such as insect guard which uses
permethrin
are they effective and safe if not how
would you recommend navigating insect
dense areas in the tropics
um these are terrible for insects
they're simply terrible for insects and
they make your experience of
walking around the jungle for instance
uh somewhat more comfortable
but you're killing insects and uh what
we saw when we were
there last when we were the amazon last
in january of 2020
was i mean still plenty of mosquitoes to
bite you
but many many fewer insects and many
many fewer insectivorous birds and this
wasn't just our observation there are
the data to
support these observations that we know
these these anecdotes
these angela observations that we met on
the ground we then found in fact one of
the people was actually there
he's been doing the bird surveys over
the last several decades and he said yep
they're plummeting especially the
insectivorous birds
because the insects are plummeting and
you know why all is it you know is it
people's
insecticide laden pants primarily
no um but it's not helping yeah i mean i
i think these things probably aren't
healthy for you
i always wonder you know the the stuff
that is supposed to repel
insects seems to be awfully toxic how
much you know how much is there
repelling
based on the fact that you know the
creatures have a detection for something
toxic anyway i never mess with insect
repellent yeah
i remember um back in the day
i think it was still a film camera back
when i was shooting with some beautiful
canon yeah slr um
and i was early enough in our in
doing field work that um i did i did
have deet with me
and i had applied it and been careful
like you up god if if you ever touch
that stuff just don't touch
anything else like you'll kill
amphibians almost on
on contact but um i just i thought i'd
clean myself off
and i went to hold the camera and i left
impregnated fingerprint that had melted
the plastic on the back of my canon
camera body and i was like that's it i'm
shocked i am i am through
yeah but the other thing i mean i
haven't been a fan of
deep since i was a yeah and permethrin
is chrysanthemum-based like this this is
it's a botanical it's better it's
botanical it's certainly the way to go
if you're going to do it
and you know there is something to be
said for something that you're not
wearing
right pyrethrum candle
down wind of you for example um there's
also something to be said for
understanding how the mosquitoes find
you that they're basically following co2
plumes and that you can therefore
you know if you create a co2 plume it's
likely to be followed by mosquitoes
it is certainly worth saying that if you
know breathing does that
yeah but breathing in one place
air flow all those things i'm just it
you could have been taken to be
suggesting that just you know cease your
co2 plume when you're safe
there are some people i wouldn't mind
seeing them see stair co2 plume but
um but nonetheless first of all it you
gotta say
if you're fearing the tropics because as
bad as things are mosquito-wise here in
the temperate zone they've got to be
worse in the tropics this is just not
true the absolute worst places are
you know like uh you know places and
i've been
worst mosquito i ever saw were in maine
right i know montana alaska i've heard
yeah but i mean they're for those of you
who aren't as attractive to the
mosquitoes as those of us who are
um i you know it certainly can be bad
especially if you're doing like animal
behavior which requires that you
actually just sit still and keep your
co2 plume where it is right
and you know i did for instance i as you
know
i began carrying mosquito coils like lit
mosquito coils
and i was like circling around my head
to keep them away and i you know
once set myself on fire because i was
actually watching the frogs and
you know what you need yes a diving bell
i need a diving belt
all right you don't need a diagonal but
okay
mosquitoes are bad in the temperate zone
they're different bad in the tropics
yeah there are often ways of managing
them that people who
have to deal with them know and learning
their tricks is much better than
importing some technological fix but
don't set yourself on fire
but don't set yourself on fire yeah
indeed luckily i was in the jungle so i
didn't it didn't spread
right i just smoldered a bit left a hole
in my quick dry pants
okay next question what do you two
evolutionary biologists think about the
possibility of life in our solar system
beyond earth
what about europa or the moons around
saturn brett you get extra points if you
can add a dad joke into your response
oh i mean the performance anxiety in
this case
is through the roof i shouldn't have
read that last part but then you
wouldn't have known about the extra
points so
so um actually i think i get points for
the performance anxiety thing
yeah okay yeah all right okay sure yeah
how many points uh this is this is lefty
but not liberal no
no no sorry lefty but not loony nice
very good
cool um uh i doubt it
i i think there is certainly life
elsewhere in
the galaxy even and i i hope um for
conscious life elsewhere in the galaxy
even but in the solar system
i doubt it i don't think so yeah there's
something
well you know i don't i don't feel like
absolutely no no way know how but i
doubt
it yeah my my instinct is the
preconditions for life
uh are the question that if you get the
right preconditions
the cascade of selective events that
then results in
adaptations and our idea our idea of
goldilocks zone is
you know very human-centric so you know
moons of
saturn yeah but it's pretty freaking
chilly out there
it is but goldilocks zone is you know
our bias yeah but but i'm not even
talking about that i'm just talking
about the um
the lack of energy the lack of energy
and how how dynamic a system it creates
and whether that results in the kind of
selection
that is necessary to get you all the way
to adaptation um
i'd love it i'm not expecting anything
super cool
on the moon on europa or yeah it's it's
yeah yeah it's gonna be matte like
we're floating like right yeah plankton
but i mean how cool would it be to you
know see a little
ooze that didn't come from here right i
think that would be great
you and i both do yes it's part of why
we're together yes
yes you get excited about you know whose
that didn't come from here
a uh what would you call it say a
properly exotic ooze
yes properly exotic ooze that wouldn't
recognize high tea if it hit in its face
if it even has a face it probably
doesn't work no it doesn't tend to
okay this is a i think it's one question
but it's in three parts here
you've said that school's primary defect
was that it didn't fit normal human
motivational structures
and that school should be self-rewarding
such that you were not driven to succeed
to please others
i was raised in a family culture and
it's a it's a female name
asking the question i was raised in a
female culture where excellence in
school was the golden ticket out of
financial hardship
growing up there was no demonstrated
interest whatsoever in the actual
workings of the subject of study
five years post-graduation i have a
bio-sci degree from the top college in
my country
i find myself depressed apathetic and
unmotivated resentful and fearful of
learning and making mistakes
any advice on how i could stop being a
cog and a job i hate
and work toward acquiring knowledge and
skills that i'm interested in and
fulfilled
by it's tragic
it is tragic but i also think i also
think that there's there's hope for you
because
what you need is to find
the question the venue whatever it is
where your search can lead you to
something
important enough that you will
understand it to be
a very good thing to have found it and
even just the fact of searching for it
will cause there to be a you know a
hunger
and so anyway my point is really about
foothills right that
the key for figuring out how to retool
yourself is finding the event
that constitutes your first taste of
that other thing that you want to
accomplish and that you can learn from
that allows you oh that was pretty good
that was cool that was a small eureka
moment but i liked it
right and then the point is well okay if
that's how you get to that one
what else would i be interested in maybe
bigger game right yeah
well and that's you know it it probably
feels like it's too late but it's not
and you know and frankly you wouldn't be
asking this question here if you really
really thought it was too late and
at some level it's never too late i do
think
that much of the world
and much of science and many scientists
teach science you say you have a
bioscience degree
as if it's the textbook it's rote
learning it's rote memorization
it's feeding back lists of facts it's
you know if you have a bullet point
list then you have the thing and that's
really the antithesis of science
right that's like the conclusions of
science that we think are true at one
time and hopefully we're mostly accurate
but
it's not what science actually is and so
trying to figure
you know trying to remember maybe where
you have been
interested in um you know where there
have been little glimmers of like oh i
wonder what i wonder if um i wonder why
in the arena where you are working you
know start to pursue those and you know
find the foothills as brett says and
and and move from there yeah i'm
reminded of uh
what students first reaction when you
take them into a tropical forest often
is
right where you know our experiences
there are questions all over right you
walk through the forest and most of the
questions are little
right but they're there and they
they shout themselves at you if you know
how to listen
um but until you know how to listen
it just looks like a sea of green well
this i mean
this is something i actually wrote into
my first book right that this was
exactly my
concern when our first professor walked
us into
into the forest in costa rica he said
you know he sort of opened up his arm he
said
look at all the questions it's like oh i
see it's green
like i don't see any questions at all
right
but if you know i mean let's let's say
that it took you two weeks
right and you don't you're walking and
you don't see a single question you see
some cool stuff but you can't figure it
out
if it took you two weeks to get your to
your first question what's your first
question very long it's not very long
and your first question is the key to
understanding you get a search image so
called
for such things and so to the extent
that you've found one
and the point is oh well all right i
know how i found that
and then you find a bunch more like it
and then you find a few that aren't like
it and next thing you know
they're all over the place so something
like that
good luck yeah
um we have three just wonderful
comments here all send money to these
good honest thinking people
critical thinkers support our own
economy to feed those willing to
consider ideas against the priests and
pharisees of our time masquerading as
scientists
thank you that's awesome thank you and
thank you heather and brett for being
guiding lights in a time of darkness
sanity in a time of insanity
curiosity in a time of absolutes free
thinkers in a time of forced compliance
of thought
i just bought the book on audible
awesome
awesome and thank you heather thank you
brett much appreciation from somerset
england you are the highlight of my week
and then this did you know that amazon
lists dianetics as a related product to
your book
also heather please allow brett to make
more dad jokes the painful jokes
outweigh the pain from working out
um no i did not know that amazon lists
diabetics as a related product and what
the hell are they doing
yeah what what is that i don't know
it's it you know it's beginning it
yeah it's maybe right right okay
oh i am now you know
that's del ron hubbard right yeah yeah
it's not a cult it's evolution god's
sake
you're talking about our thing our thing
yes
this all of this functional medics
suggest that fasting could be a reset
for gut health
hypothesis extends to autoimmune
disorders hormone and insulin
suppression is key
have you seen any research that feels
evolutionarily likely
so i'm not sure exactly what that final
you know evolutionarily likely
exactly means but um yeah we've we've
talked here
i'm not sure we talk actually much in
the book in our in our food chapter
about um
intermittent fasting but we have talked
here before
and elsewhere about um both the
physiological evidence for it being a
great way to reset gut health
and basically decrease inflammation
which seems to be one of the key factors
in
so much illness among so many moderns
but then another
another completely different line of
evidence for its value
is how many different cultural
traditions uh use some form of
intermittent fasting
right so you know from well at the
moment i'm only coming up with one which
is you know ramadan
for muslims but there are there are many
peoples and traditions across time and
space
um that have used imf intermittent
fasting in some form
and that suggests right there that there
is some value to it
yes it is also the case that whether one
chooses to do it or not an
ancestor would very likely have faced it
enforced by
the environment and its uneven rate at
which it coughs up things to eat
um so anyway yes there is an argument to
be made for the fact that yeah your
system's built for it
um yeah and you know
i usually don't like the metaphor of
like a cleansing um
but i i think there's some accuracy
there here if you don't take it too far
that you know getting getting yourself
gut empty
on you know at least in
a sporadic basis if not a regular basis
um
will help make sure that you know stuff
doesn't build up yeah
yeah and it's not it's not perfect but i
think it's it's okay by analogy too
there's lots of things that we now
know require sleep to function
you know immunological things for
example um
and the point is that cycling rather
than always being sort of doing
something
yeah right and yeah sleep comes easier
sleep come sleep is better
sleep is deeper sleep is more healing um
obviously not if you're starving yeah
but if it's been more i don't know
something like
more than four hours since you've eaten
right if you're actually um that's you
know certainly if you've got alcohol in
your system
uh recently it feels easy to fall asleep
but you're really just passing out even
if you've only had a couple of drinks
like it's not it's not
sleep that you're falling into really
and it's a disturbed sleep
and i say that you know we drink it yeah
we say that not as a teetotaler messes
up your
uh your dreams sleep cycles too and so
all sorts of processing so i guess
that's the point is that
there is some sort of ancestral pattern
of
you don't always have you know your
ancestors didn't have a refrigerator
right up until very recently your very
recent ancestors had a refrigerator the
ones just slightly farther back had an
icebox and then
pretty much nothing maybe they had a
cave you don't know my ancestors
i'm not the boss of your ancestors let's
put it that's right
but in any case there would have been an
awful lot of
inadvertent fasting yes right
hey let's call it intermittent and
pretend we were trying to do that let's
be cats about this
right we'll call it rewritten and then
we can sell it
but but no but it is built into a lot of
you know
fasting and then feasting it is built
into a lot of cultural traditions as
well
well i guess the thing if so confession
don't really know what they mean by
intermittent fasting because it seems to
me like if it's not intermittent
it's famine is that wrong i think what
they mean is periodic
so like regularly like it's either
circadian or
periodic i don't know what the fancy
word for weekly is but um
yeah so it's like it's on a schedule i
think right
but yeah intermittent it's not a good
description but
in any case
oh oh can they hear what you're saying
zach
okay so yeah you could so zach our
producer who is currently not speaking
into a mic
says think of the intermittent setting
on windshield wipers
zack who drives now um and well
too he drives well and apparently knows
how to use his windshield and
joe said well he does live in the
pacific northwest so that's not that
surprising but he points out that
it's like the intermittent setting on
windshield wipers which is just the
medium the medium thing and i guess both
of those uses of intermittent are not
generally what i think of when i think
intermittent no
i think of the maddening phenomenon when
something is wrong with your vehicle but
the problem is
in intermittent i know it's not
happening now exactly yes
so i'm not sure it's all that helpful i
think
periodic fasting would be a much better
uh better description but anyway because
that's a
an ancient phenomenon that would have
been enforced by nature if nothing else
a lot of things may sort of expect it to
be
and to the extent that you disrupt it
with the refrigerator phenomenon
you don't know how many cascading
effects they'll be
absolutely i just picked up my
ivermectin to implement as a
prophylactic
i understand that your family has chosen
that mode as well what dose do you
recommend
incidentally my doctor refused to
prescribe me avermectin and suggested
either
i think there's a word missing here
either of
t to which i said no i think it's
probably
either the vaccines maybe um i'm not
sure
the doc that prescribed it the the
doctor did prescribe it told me to take
one a week for three weeks thoughts will
it be protected
so go onto the flccc website and look
for the
mask protocol but
i will say so i have to say this
we are not doctors we are scientists we
are
not in a position to give you medical
advice we can tell you something about
how we look at things and you can
take it as you will but the thing that i
would say
is the data and i was special especially
struck
by the fact that there are apparently
very strongly measurable effects in
populations that use
ivermectin for preventing
parasites preventing and treating
parasites and that those usages the
prophylactic use is
uh much rarer than the prophylactic dose
that one would extrapolate from the
flccc documents so
here's the question it seems that this
drug
is very very safe so
there may be i would you know no drug is
perfectly safe
all drugs have impacts on your liver um
and i don't want to be on anything for
the rest of my life right
right my assumption is that you know
hopefully we
can get a handle on the community we're
talking tanks to
a couple of years and anyway it's not
that long i do too but you know a couple
of years
uh seems likely to be safe but here's
the question what we are not finding out
because we are busy pretending that
there is no
evidence that this works is we are not
finding out
okay one of the studies the argentina
study showed
a hundred percent effectiveness not a
huge study but it was 800
well just let's let's just be careful um
so it was 800 ish it was like 790
something so call it 800
who were given the ivermectin protocol
on 400 who were not
of those 800 some considerable fraction
i don't know what the number is some
considerable fraction
actually exactly followed the protocol
of that considerable fraction of the 800
who perfectly followed the protocol
there was a hundred percent
efficacy but there were some people in
that 800 again i don't know the
percentage
who didn't totally follow the protocol
and they were not totally
completely covered okay from cloven but
presumably
perfectly perfectly accurate and precise
if possible
presumably a category that says
a binary category did or didn't follow
the protocol did follow the protocol
means one thing and one thing only
didn't follow the protocol can mean
anything
anything except the one thing so what
that means is there could be people who
didn't take any in that group so
if we limit the analysis to those who
followed the protocol
we see something like 100 protection now
i'm not claiming that that
pattern would continue if you got a much
larger data set it might it might not
don't know but there's no
a priori reason to think it wouldn't
well right
and the point would be this if you
if you um are
always uh how do i put it
100 protection suggests that the dose is
too
high right right what you really want
because
assuming that the dose was not chosen
for some reason that reached 100
and probably we don't know what dose
reaches 100 because
you need a lot of study to figure out
exactly what that dose is
the point is it's probably a guess and
so if it gets if a guess reaches 100
then what you want to do is say how much
in excess
is that guess of the necessary thing and
you want to back it off
until you get to the number where 100 is
just barely maintained
and this is actually related to an
important point that we should probably
make on the main podcast at some point
which is that
you know and actually this is something
i found when i first started looking at
ivermectin
whatever that was a couple three weeks
ago now
which was one of the first things you
run into is
uh but the dose basically the dose
needed to treat is
100 times the toxic level
you know the recommended level and it's
guaranteed to be toxic and therefore you
can't use it
and what that number is based on is some
animal trial some animal model trial
in which they just chose an amount they
just chose a dosage
and found indeed that it was protective
um but
they they weren't saying that's the
dosage that you need
right they were just saying well this is
the first one we tried and it
worked and so what you then do is you
titrate isn't the right word but you
basically back it off
um in successive trials which is
effectively what we've
had done in like slovakia and czech
republic and panama mexico and india and
all these other countries now i don't
think it was an animal trial
i think it was a tissue trial oh yes no
you're right it was in vitro right
yeah so yes so even worse because even
really it's
completely it's completely
misinformative because really i'm not
saying that the experiment was bad
but what it was was in the early past
in the early days of covid right you
have a disease
you don't know what might work right
you don't want to you know give some
uh anti-helminth drug
you don't want to give such a weak dose
of a drug that something
useful shows no effect so you err in the
direction of let's just see
especially in vitro like you're not
you're right you're not even harming
lab animals which you shouldn't want to
harm but you know like in vitro you're
due
like this is doing no harm this is a
quick and dirty survey to see what
molecules
show promise and are worth studying so
to take that as if it's an india these
people think
that dose is tolerable to people no
nobody said that right what they're
doing is they're just looking for what
molecules work
so anyway that's yes good on a related
note what's up with hissing
cats hiss geese hiss my ex-girlfriend's
hiss
why is that a common warning also you
shouldn't be wearing hats like those
without a bolo tie
this is al quinn again he always wants
you in a bolo tie not me though i'm not
wearing a bowler tie but neither are you
true i mean i don't think my hat
requires a bolo tie
no it doesn't yeah my hat which is now
still a very weird color for me because
my red hat got destroyed in the boat
accident
right that was the death of the red hat
anyway i'm near the death of you but
yes yes i i lost a you know
a treasure no people but uh a hat yep
a bunch of other stuff but okay what's
up with hissing apparently al's
ex-girlfriend's hiss
and cats hiss and geez and other things
how could this person
ow i assume al is a guy how could al
have missed cockroaches
yeah in madagascar the cockroaches yeah
um i'll just take a wild guess
i think this is going to start with some
creature and this is like aposomatic but
it's sound so aposomatic is when a
creature is colorful or has a pattern on
it that alerts you
that it shouldn't be messed with because
it wouldn't have such a bold pattern if
it was tasty for example so
um in any case if you imagine that there
are you know if if there are snakes that
hiss and there are
well i was just gonna say i think i know
where you're going this is like
apostomatic for
the sound a snake makes as it tastes the
air
right well i don't know i was imagining
you think they're actually
actively hissing as opposed to that's
because that's the like
that's the the two-pronged right tongue
out that then goes into the foam or
nasal organ
sure but is there a sound i haven't
noticed the sound but i
you don't get close enough to snakes man
small ones the sound maybe is
not that profound i i have never heard a
sound from from a snake uh
tasting the air and doing the
vomeronasal thing but i do think that
there are some snakes that hiss
but i may be responding to uh a myth
i was hoping that you'd know as the as
the herpetologist of the two of us
yeah um i i i don't know well you know
what we're gonna find out
really soon right people are gonna
contact us but if in fact there is some
frightening creature
that hisses i mean i guess i was saying
i think snakes do hiss but i don't think
it's a particular subset
of of snakes but i'm not sure about that
it's not that i
never occurred to me if snake says like
yes snakes snakes yes
all right well if snakes hiss then it's
probably an allusion to that and in fact
we can come up with
another example you're probably going to
know which snake
and there there's more than one but
there's at least one snake that
is not a rattler but uses dry leaves and
wiggles its tail to create a rattle-like
sound oh yeah um yeah someone
that's some patrick with rattlesnakes
but of course rattlesnakes are got a big
broad range
yeah i can't i mean it may even be just
you know also garter snakes are also
ubiquitous big broad range they may do
it
um but it might it might more likely be
someone who's also visually
episomatic yeah completely copying
rattlesnakes
um i can't i think i think that is a
known behavior and i can't think of who
it is i'm sure it's a number
tell us i've read about it and i've
heard it but i can't remember what i
could go get my big book of snakes
it's a good one next time all right
um we didn't really yeah we did we're
good congratulations to zach on making
it to rocketry championships
your son is literally a rocket scientist
and the unsung hero of the dark horse
podcast
yes he is yeah he's awesome
i'm sorry i have to correct you we sing
to him sometimes when he refuses to get
out of bed in the morning
he doesn't like it which is why it works
so he's been sung
he's not the unsung yeah he's the sung
hero he's the sung hero of the dark
person you know i think
even though i mean probably it's not his
favorite moment to be sung to if we
picked a different song he'd probably
appreciate it
wasn't appalling yeah he says any other
song
we picked the worst song we could think
of and also remember the lyrics too
yes yeah maybe we'll just leave it at
that and let people guess
i think we will and maybe we'll tell you
next time and it is not
it's reigning men
[Laughter]
that might be a close second
what advice would you give a 46 year old
wanting to learn more about math
i am a right-brained thinker who never
grasped anything beyond the basics
thank you alison um
i mean it depends on what kind of math
you're talking about um you know
something like khan academy is really
really great actually um and you know
they have they have better and worse
arenas but um but it's pretty great
um i guess i guess i would want to know
what like what kind of math you're
interested in
uh the you know the the twitter account
run by our friend
um it's called great women of
mathematics gwo
maths uh is terrific and you pick up
math here and there and it also does
sort of um you know history of math
stuff but it's also got
actual math yes and it is it is open to
you no matter what you were identified
as at birth
sorry um
all right i have now interrupted your
flow oh go for it um what do you have to
say about math
i was going to add one thing i i don't
have
anything really useful to offer on how
do you get into math
i would say the thing i experienced
was whether or not you had a teacher
who loved the subject and understood it
deeply made all the difference math was
incredibly painful when the teacher
didn't really get it or care
so that's it's hard for a 46 year old
right
but in that vein i was going to
recommend a particular mathematical
thing that i
thought was super cool and actually
points you to a teacher that i would
recommend
vihart who is on youtube has
a number of videos that are how's that
spell vi
i think h-a-r-t um anyway vi heart
um has one video i would suggest you
start with
which is on the fibonacci
sequence in nature i think it's
pretty marvelous this is fight heart yep
that's vi heart
so zach you can show this briefly um
okay anyway her thing is a cool a cool
channel
and uh and the fibonacci sequence in
nature thing is especially good because
uh i will just i think we've talked
about it once before actually but
you um if you look around in plants and
you see all the fibonacci sequences
you think my god what's going on here
are the plants better at math than we
thought
and in fact something else entirely is
going on and those are fibonacci
sequences but they
they got there a different way and
they're there for a really good reason
it's super cool
so anyway we can maybe return to that
some other time but but it's cool stuff
and i guess i would say um you know
again you know this this won't be
helpful
because um it's you know about the
particular situation that i had growing
up my father was a mathematician and
uh he instilled in me such a deep love
of math because it was
it was everywhere and we were always
playing at math and
he had actually when i announced that i
was going to become a biologist he was
like why biology is the least
interesting science
and i think before he died we managed to
compel him i think um
that that was but yeah it was not his
instinct it was not his instinct and so
when i was growing up playing in math
space all the time it wasn't
about you know finding fibonacci
sequences and plants it was
much more um well it was about practical
it was about engineering it's about
putting up fences and you know making
sure things didn't fall and such
and um purely abstract and just like the
beauty of the numbers
and for for me that got me there but i'm
not sure that um
that if you were coming late to it that
you that you would
you know i wish now that you mention it
given that your dad was not on board
with biology at first
that we had been able to have the
conversation with him about
mandelbrot right so my
uh my um investigation of mandelbrot got
cut
short by what happened in in 2017 at
evergreen
um but the
insight that drove mondelbrot to
discover what he did
this is fractals guy was fractals was
that effectively
math as instantiated at the time is
inadequate to deal with biology
right that there are processes and yeah
he's 19th century or he's no
twenty-seven he's 20th century and in
fact um he
oh yeah okay yeah i had him he may even
still be alive
really probably not but uh anyway yeah
was it bell labs no he was at ibm i
think
but anyway he he noticed that there were
certain mathematical problems that
created paradoxes that needed some
different kind of mathematics
so for example if you have a shoreline
and you want to know
what the uh the distance along the shore
is the finer and finer you measure the
greater the distance because you've got
all these undulations right down to the
molecular
level and so effectively the finer you
measure if you measure with infinite
uh fineness you get an infinite
shoreline no matter how short it is
right so that's that's a mathematical
paradox and anyway he found these things
in biology and he pursued them
and figured out how you address these
things and he didn't i don't think he
invented fractals but he
took a very crude fractal science and
advanced it uh
radically and anyway i would love to
have had the conversation with your dad
about here's where biology and math meet
and it meets in a place you won't notice
because mathematically we didn't get
anywhere near good enough for this for
to characterize the math that your dad
would have studied
yep absolutely uh so you were much
closer to right here he was
mandelbrot was born in 20 1924 and died
in 2010
2010 yeah yeah uh
what time are we at zack you are at
55 oh okay um let us
there's just some commenty questions
here let's get through them quickly and
then move into the next hour
um this is super cool scott adams gave
you high praise
in his stream this morning regarding
ivermectin while also offering tips for
how scientists in general can gain more
credibility
with those who lack a scientific
background please check it out
cool that's great yeah that's awesome
appreciate it thanks scott
yeah uh during questioning about our
help to other countries biden mentioned
ivermectin by name as support that we
would be sending i can't find this clip
anywhere on youtube do you have thoughts
love you guys
so i'm reading that not because i've
heard of this at all but so that it's
i don't know i don't know anything about
this but i'd love to see that
yeah i'd love to see um biden talking
about that and then of course that would
raise the questions of why we don't
let that happen here but so i don't know
anything about it
um do you see any evidence of
any variant posing a greater threat than
the base sars kovi
ii and do you have thoughts or feelings
regarding giveaways and lotteries to
incentivize getting the vaccine
um i think some of the variants
are more highly transmissible i haven't
seen anything
about them um having higher fatality
rates
i've owned i've only seen stuff about
transmissibility yep
and but there's the data are so crap
that i don't know what that means
right that are being shared with us the
transmissibility data now
exists in the confusing environment in
which you've got people vaccinated so
yeah yeah so the extent to which we are
now causing i would say the thing i fear
more than the variance is the diversity
yeah right the diversity of of uh of
sars kovi ii variants is frightening
because it's a harder puzzle to deal
with
by a lot so maybe what
if i may rephrase the thing that you
fear that i agree with
the thing that you fear more than any
individual variant is
the number and array and diversity of
variants
yeah and i worry a lot
that uh garrett vandenbush
might be right about the relationship
i've seen
i've seen some data that has a scary
connection now it's possible you know
there's a lot that's he may be right
that mass vaccination
um during a pandemic can drive new
variants
right that's the thing that you
certainly write about it in principle
um in practice that we could make things
far worse in other words
a scenario in which we come close to
you know if we were smart and we
ivermectined our way there that'd be one
thing but let's say
we got close to vaccinating our way out
of the pandemic
and it generates a variant so far
removed from the modern vaccines
that we effectively restart it right
that is a frightening scenario so anyway
it is
don't know but i would say it's the it's
the diversity of the variants
more than it is any individual one
what do you think about the incentives
to uh oh yeah
i hate this yeah i do i hate this it's
it's for shame really for sure right so
especially in light of the fact that
what's really
what's really going on here is you've
got hesitancy i'm sure some of the
hesitancy
is loony and a lot of the hesitancy is
not loony and for you to incentivize
people
into ignoring the hazard that they feel
even though you do it because you think
you're doing the right thing for planet
earth you're leading people to ignore a
danger that you are not in a position to
say does not exist
and that makes you responsible for what
happens
downstream of that event i would also
point out
and i can't remember who said this to me
somebody in the last day or two somebody
pointed out
the um
i will figure out who it was i haven't
talked to that many people
the classist
nature of such incentives right the
wealthier you are
the easier it is to ignore and the more
likely you are to be educated enough to
ignore
a lottery being used to induce you to
face some hazard that you
instinctively otherwise would it would
be
be held back by and so the extent to
which we are going to
end up extending the experiment of these
vaccines to people
who are not as well positioned to resist
the carrot that we
are delivering or not as
capable of seeing past the unlikeliness
that a lottery
will smile upon them right there's
something very very wrong
and again the obsession with vaccinating
everybody
i would be so on board if these things
were clearly safe or if we had reason to
believe the system
was excellent at doing that and that the
only thing there was was a tiny chance
of a long-term harm but i don't think
that's where we are
yep either okay
quickly two more um what is the reaction
to your no-no medicine
ivermectin podcast ben like both
privately and publicly
overwhelming support
the mechanisms that distribute it have
behaved
very oddly i've seen anomalies on
the youtube whatever it's called the
youtube studio app i've never seen
before
things behave strangely the numbers were
going up
up up really really fast and then they
hit this
youtube molasses phenomenon yesterday
where the rate suddenly plummets to near
zero
and the graph of
views does not show a discontinuity or a
plateau it's perfectly smooth so it sort
of looks like something behind the
scenes
wants this not to be visible but if
you're paying attention to the number of
people who've seen it there's something
clearly happened same thing happens on
twitter
there's been a lot of hostility um
a lot of that hostility is garbagey you
know
you know you don't know it works uh
prove it this kind of thing
um why aren't you talking about how
great vaccines are right
you know blood on your hands kind of
stuff um
and then there's the sock puppet thing
where they're all of these sock puppet
accounts or burner accounts or whatever
they are that
you know if you just simply click
through to them they look so
weird you know oh you've got 16
followers and you signed up in 2009
and you follow 800 people
i don't know what that is but that's not
organic so
there's something that wants the
conversation to have a certain sound and
it keeps chiming in and trying to
control the conversation
so anyway it's very confusing that's the
answer to your question
one last question here and then we'll
move to a few questions from this hour
if brett is maverick does that mean
heather is iceman
zach that's a reference to the movie top
gun i trust your parents have educated
you sufficiently in this regard
now zach i don't remember actually i
know we watched top gun
um with toby recently but it's possible
you were you were there you weren't out
doing rock tree at the time
okay okay so um
i think we've both got a few
characteristics of of of the maverick
character and of the
of the iceman character i totally don't
remember these characters well enough to
say anything about it really
well let's see maverick is uh is is his
main dude um tom cruise yes so i would
say
physical resemblance definitely it's not
for me no for me
um and iceman is
oh what's his name it's uh yeah i i
can't remember his name
oh wait wait it's uh yes was it belle
gilman yeah was it falcon i think so the
guy who then who then plays jim morrison
right right totally yeah that's about
all i got
um but no i mean the character i think i
think iceman is called that because he
just he is
he keeps it completely cool when he's in
the cockpit he does
he does he does not make errors there
and
maverick it runs hotter and um
i think i think there are places um
there are domains
in our lives where each of those
descriptions are a better fit for you
and a better fit for me and it's not
it's not
all one yep yep all right
um oh my goodness look at how many
amazing
questions wow i really appreciate it
guys and i'm sorry we won't get your
tropical forest yes all i see are words
um i brought i brought i bought
1.87 ivermectin paste for my horse
for homogeneous paste i could compute
the dosage for a 180 pound
horse i know you aren't medics or vets
but are there any unsafe downsides of
another species
consumed it ah um
i can only tell you what i've heard and
read
which is that it's the same stuff and
the animal stuff tastes like apples yeah
i mean it wouldn't surprise me if there
was
something different in the formulation
that certainly you know
even if you like crunchy food you
probably don't snack on your cat's
kibble
right like you know they're lesser
generally the standards are lower and we
there are
certainly some things that humans can
eat that um
our animals cannot and presumably vice
versa is true as well
so i'd you know that is all true and
um i don't i don't know but i think
again the flccc has some
has some stuff on this well the flccc
will help you they will prescribe
ivermectin and there are other ways to
get it i certainly
bought ivermectin i can't remember
exactly how it worked
if there was a pharmacy and it had a
doctor and you had a consult
that was at least available but um
i don't but we have heard from people
the horse stuff tastes like apples
i think the horse stuff famously i think
and there and those people are still
around
well we don't know we don't know what
fraction of them are still around but
those who were still around report that
it
tastes like apples let's put it this way
um i sourced human ivermectin because
it's preferable
on the other hand in an emergency i
wouldn't have hesitated you know this is
me
it's not you i wouldn't have hesitated
in an emergency
because the fact is covid
does damage over time the later you
apply this stuff the less likely it is
to work and the less effective it's
going to be
and so time is of the essence and
like that but yeah yeah
can we imagine a means for otherwise
safe ivermectin to have a long-term risk
interacting with covid
also how hard it would be to engineer a
serial passage to this effect either
well or ill-intentioned
wait wait wait i don't get the last part
yeah much i don't
i don't know like ivermectin
isn't alive so you can't serial passage
ivermectin
um it doesn't change as it goes through
organisms right um it is it is a static
medicine
um but so the first one can we imagine a
means for otherwise safe i've remembered
to have long-term risk interacting with
covid
uh hold on a second
i'm trying so the the landscape that
you're looking in
is the following thing you got
antibodies
and you've got receptors that work like
antibodies but are on the cell surface
and they're basically a structural set
of proteins
and then they have a variable tips right
they're y-shaped you've seen you know
the diagram
we've all seen of antibodies are whys
floating around
those tips are variable they're
electromagnetically variable
and so they stick to stuff that's unique
to them whereas the rest of the antibody
is generic at least within the category
of antibody that it is
but as your immune system develops an
affinity for something if you get
vaccinated let's say let's say the
vaccine works exactly as
planned the spike protein comes to the
surface of your cell the
immune system regards it as foreign it
basically sees your cell as infected
with virus
it learns the virus signature by
contacting the spike protein
there is selection that then produces
cells that are better and better at
sticking to the spike protein
okay that's how it's all supposed to
work
the ivermectin binds to the spike
protein
and so has impacts on that process
and it is also the case that
antibodies can create their inverse
the immune system can react to
antibodies and it can create
the inverse sticky uh pattern right so
all sorts of things are possible in this
landscape where
you know if if it is true that
antibodies pick up the inverse
of the spike protein in order to stick
to it then the inverse of an antibody
that has the the antibody that has the
spike protein imprint and the inverse of
that antibody is a different antibody
now looks like spike protein
in some regard now i don't think it will
look enough like spike protein
to matter right in other words it's not
going to
you know stick to ace 2 well enough to
disrupt the cell
in all likelihood but is it conceivable
if something down that road could happen
in principle sure lots of things are yes
well i guess this is i was
maybe my version of this question
earlier this week was
is there are we at risk of uh
ivermectin equivalent of antibiotic
resistance right right
it's exactly that that analogy and
uh we sort of concluded probably not
but theoretically is it completely
outside the realm of the positive
possibility it's not
it's not completely outside the realm of
possibility but it's much less
likely because ivermectin is
non-specific right
i mean it is it's
it's insanely non-specific like it's it
is it really does seem to be
one of less than a handful of wonder
drugs with regard to
the general nature of things it will
bind to
and cure you of which i should point out
is why i want to see the dosage
driven down to the absolute minimum
necessary to do the job right because
because like antibiotics we risk driving
all sorts of other things that might be
our symbionts out with with it right
if this is a super sticky awesome
molecule then the point is actually
as little as possible thank you very
much i'd like as little as possible of
that to get the job done
yeah you know short term it matters less
than long term to be sure
um but boy would it be great to stop
pretending it didn't work and start
figuring out how best to use it
that's crazy talk probably
a key phrase as of late seems to be
pyramid scheme maybe it's a key meme
which ones do you see collapsing i hope
you enjoy a weekend off and thanks for
the essential lifeboat through these
times
it's interesting i haven't i actually
haven't seen pyramid scheme come up but
um i'm trying to
not pay attention to as much of what's
just coming across feeds
i want to frame it a little differently
okay go for it pyramid scheme is the
only game in town
why because it profits faster than
anything else
so what that means is those of us who
want to do real stuff in the world and
not play the pyramid scheme game
are going to lose to those who play the
pyramid scheme game and play it well
right the pyramids game game can also be
called the bubble game
right the the financial crisis of 2008
was basically a
a scheme whereby the particular
thing in question was mortgages and
mortgage-backed securities
and credit default swaps and the other
things that allowed the thing to happen
but the basic point was a bubble
began to emerge those who understood
where the bubble was could ride it
up and escape before it collapsed
leaving the you know a huge destruction
of wealth and the bill
handed to other people largely us the
public who had to bail out the
institutions in order to
restore the world economy but the basic
point is if you're real
if you really want to be a billionaire
right you probably want to get
good at the bubble game and get rid of
everything else from
your mind figure out how to just
recognize the next bubble how to
understand
when to get in when to get out that kind
of thing that's going to be the quickest
route to the top and it is
not only not productive it is absolutely
destructive right we're living in a
bubble economy
where this is the game so anyway my
point is why is
pyramid scheme everywhere because
pyramid schemes are everywhere
um you know to a greater and lesser
degree and
the danger that this puts us all in is
massive
so it ought to be the highest priority
to
figure out how to make pyramid schemes
not pay
that's the key thing they have to stop
paying or you're going to see nothing
but them from here on
yes good is genetic immunity to covid
possible
due to higher innate immunity towards
flu for instance
my dad and i are the only two people we
know of on our street who tested
negative during india's second wave peak
spread
that's interesting i will bet you that
there is
genetic immunity and probably of a
couple of different kinds exactly
that's what that's what would be my
guess you know based on no data at all
but that would be my guess but highly
likely that some people
are all but immune or completely immune
and then there's a question of whether
you could acquire immunity
without encounter with kovid so that you
are walking around
genetically as if vaccinated from
you know from before the pandemic ever
began yep
next question someone asked about the
rates of vaccination for indian states
excuse me goa 39 delhi 35 percent
um tn
is uh tamil nadu 14
and utter pradesh 10 calculated for 15
states and the range is 10 to 39
that's and that's apparently from that
same source ap dot cova 19 india.org
that um
the data were being gathered from to
make those graphs that i showed
using only one dose so percentage um
is from zero to two hundred uh that's
interesting i didn't see the question
about asking about rates of vaccination
for indian states but i was actually
thinking
um actually if you would show my screen
again zach
that let me just go back to this one so
this is all four of the states
that were just mentioned this is uh goa
and uttar pradesh
and delhi and tamil nadu
as i was looking at these as i was
preparing these uh
for today i was thinking what i really
want is these same graphs with
vaccination rates overlaid
uh so that we can see
so that we could see the two obvious
things you know duvac does
does early vaccination slow the spread
of cases or fatalities
and does that interface with the spread
of
with the widespread distribution of
ivermectin yep
and um and of course
the question isn't does widespread
vaccination
slow the spread or not the question
unfortunately
is does widespread vaccinations slow the
spread do not much to the spread
or accelerate the spread perhaps of new
variants
um yes and what does it do to the rate
of death
yeah another question exactly um imagine
though you remember back in the early
days of covid
when just like right after 9 11
suddenly there was journalism everywhere
and people who were had been in the
corporate machine and were doing
pseudo-journalism were suddenly
reporting on stuff and it was wild and
yeah um and science came to life as
kobut was new and everybody was trying
to figure out what was going on
oh the pre-print servers wow they got
the wild west yeah on
peer review it's the wild west but there
was lots of stuff to talk about
yeah it was great um imagine that that
was going on now
that instead of having settled back into
whatever the you know
the game is currently we were excited
about the fact that we had various tools
at our disposal it would be freaking
great to figure out what their
interaction was
which ones were safe which ones weren't
what the best treatment was from the
cost-benefit analysis perspective
people could be furiously at work
figuring out what do we do now
collectively because we're all in this
together
instead to continue your analogy we're
all looking for weapons of mass
destruction
yeah in iraq we're looking for websites
i mean that's that's
it that like we all bought a story
we're told like a bunch of journalism
happened and they were like oh this is
it this is where we go i have no one
look at the man behind the curtain
and yes we are looking for weapons of
mass destruction in iraq while the
chinese are
looking for the real killer of oj's
ex-wife
chinese well i'm figuring they're
they're
looking for the population of creatures
or people in which the virus was
circulating before it got to wuhan
okay you know yeah sure they are okay
um have you heard the idea that there
was potential motive for a purposeful
lab leak due to trump's trade deal with
china having a force major clause
i have not heard that nope so
i haven't heard it i haven't heard it i
will just say if your thing
is intentional not leak right
you have a fact you have to deal with it
made
no sense if the idea was the chinese for
example wanted to
have the have a covet 19 pandemic
made no sense to release it in wuhan
release it in yunnan we probably never
would have figured out it was a lab leak
because
those few people who figured out there
was something weird with the genome
would not have had the central fact that
called most people's attention to the
hazard here
which was this showed up in wuhan which
makes no sense so
it sounds to me like the hypothesis
being advanced here is that it was
not the chinese who released it it was
somebody else trying to
quash a deal which i ain't seen no
evidence but
uh anyway deal with the fact that
if your hypothesis is the chinese
released this to accomplish
x releasing it in wuhan didn't make any
sense right you have to at least figure
out why they would have done that and
i i have yet to see a reason yeah
okay we got a lot a lot here we're
probably well over an hour at this point
um several of these are just comments so
we're gonna i'm just gonna read through
a few more and then at some point we're
just going to have to call it a call it
a saturday we're going to call it a
saturday call it a saturday all right
fact i'll do it now
it's saturday wow yeah i had not caught
up to that fact yet but
um thought of talking to rand about
ivermectin i presume you mean rand paul
not the rand corporation
um although boy if the brand corporation
were interested they could they could
make a difference
yeah um sure uh that could um
i actually i don't i assume that if this
is about rand paul that rand paul has
been said something i actually i just
don't know i don't know
any of what's going on in in politics
space on this
i'd certainly talk to rand paul about
this for one thing i mean you know
a he's been in the right place on gain
of function
lab leak he correctly uh exposed
fauci who lied to his face and
anyway so he's been good on this he's a
doctor
he uh
i'm trying to remember exactly did he
say he'd had coveted and therefore
wasn't going to get vaccinated
i don't know i think he said that if
i've got it wrong i'm sorry but
i believe that was the story in my sense
was yeah that's exactly the right
you know reasonable people can disagree
over the uh wisdom of
getting vaccinated um in the first place
i think ivermectin actually
changes the puzzle so radically that the
reasonable person argument begins to
disappear
but the um
a person who's had covid doesn't need
the vaccine and doesn't need the risk
whatever that risk may be
so anyway what i'm saying is i've heard
rand paul make sense
several times it sounds like he's not
following the science-ish
um i got that from
uh what's his who what what video is
that
oh who is it damn
okay i'll look it up yeah um
it's a good one you keep you keep
talking man anyway all i was saying was
um i i think rand paul is making some
sense on this topic quite a bit of sense
and he's
courageous about it and there's so much
on the line here
i wouldn't under ordinary circumstances
be troubled by
crossing the aisle to talk to rand paul
but um
for god's sake this is an emergency like
i'll talk to anybody who
is anywhere in a position to help and is
capable of hearing the message and
there's no question that rand paul is
there
hey zach who was the who made the video
that i showed you
i can't figure it out i'm sorry j jt
something okay zach's gonna figure it
out because my
my half-assed attempt is searching here
not working
um okay where are my questions here we
go
do you have thoughts on aoc rejecting
the hundred thousand dollars that matt
walsh of the daily wire
raised to help aoc's grandma so many
conservatives are volunteering to help
her yet she and other leftists won't
meet us halfway
how can we bridge this divide again i
didn't know anything about this
i don't know well but yeah
you know okay so
aoc has been a very destructive force i
think she has
um played to our
sympathies and it's this kind of
weaponized empathy thing and i'm
not a fan on the other hand
i think that there's this campaign to go
after her
on the basis that she drives a tesla or
you know that her grandmother's place is
you know not nice and i think the point
is
there are supposed to be rules to this
goddamn game right
and the goddamn game is supposed to
involve leaving people's families
out of stuff right if you've got
combatants in the game
you don't go after their families right
do you really want to be scrutinized for
what car you drive do we want to go
after aoc and then us all have to
account for what car we drive
right this is insane this is lunacy aoc
is vulnerable at a policy level
let us talk about where she is wrong on
policy and if she lies
we should talk about that but i don't
believe we should be talking about
what car she drives and we should be you
know i agree we shouldn't be talking
about what car she drives
um and i actually you know i
i suspect that i agree with her on some
policy issues although i don't know
what they are at the moment um
i feel like i did see something on
twitter
about grandmother in puerto rico yeah
right so
so she she brings it in though so right
so
right there's a she she's too much ego
right and like politicians have to be
ego else they wouldn't
like they wouldn't be successful right
um
but you know she i don't think it's
it's a legitimate rhetorical move
to bring in the stuff and then say you
can't touch that stuff that's not nice
like you you brought it in you brought
it to the table no you're
you're right about this so i guess i
guess then my appeal is to both sides
right like everyone has to up their game
but whoever whichever side goes
second loses i mean no i mean i'm sorry
whichever side goes first loses
yeah you know if you lay off first and
the other side just it's rocket fuel
so i guess the point is i i think you've
you're convincing me okay so aoc drags
something in
uh to pull on heart strings right
it raises an obvious question and
i don't even know if it does like really
all i think i saw is like here's a
picture of my poor grandma's house in
puerto rico it's destroyed something
like this right
and i don't
it does pull on heart strings but it
right raise questions i don't know it
raises questions like
she she needs to be raising up all of
her beloved family members
um before she can you know
drive i don't even know she'd drop a
tesla but before she can you know
dress the part to do the job that she's
trying to do here
no that's also not how it goes so it
sounds like i've convinced you and
you've convinced me no i
i think that she's not playing a fair
game but i think that
um her her antagonists are also not
playing a fair game
and i think in this case it with regard
to
the particular thing that is aoc did she
walk under the stage and start it yes
but had it started before she ever
walked onto stage in the public eye
yes yeah so there is no you know she
started it he's
like they all started it yeah like
there's there's no tracking it back to
origin
and you know it's it's the entire
conversation that is broken
yeah i'm i'm compelled
to perhaps exactly have the solution no
well the solution yeah no we've got a
fairly corrupt system is the problem and
basically you know it's all symptoms
until you figure out
how that uh how that works but yeah
look aoc has
extended she's pushed the envelope with
respect to the rules
um she has you know i believe
manipulated us with tears
and all sorts of stuff and stories that
are exaggerated and she's pulled all
kinds of shenanigans so i'm not
sympathetic
on the other hand i do think somebody
has to speak
for you know the reasonable rules of the
game
right you can't have andy no getting the
crap beaten out of him
in the streets of portland frankly a
reporter has the right to go anywhere
they goddamn want on any street in any
american city
that they choose to report on right
antifa doesn't get a [ __ ] vote
so my point is there are rules and
that's one of them and
hey we you know grant people a certain
amount of leeway and we don't
you know nitpick the details of their
lives or what they post on social media
for any hint of hypocrisy we actually
have to be generous
to an extent in this end um so anyway
that umbrella extends to aoc
as it does to everybody else you know
whether she deserves it or not
specifically yeah yep
um this is just the same person
who was asking about if you if they
might have genetic community
having been living on a street
somewhere in india they don't specify
where this person and their father i
think we're the only two people who
haven't gotten coveted to put it in
context i've been in the covet hospital
and patients have coughed near me i was
masked i've lived in the same house with
three people who tested positive
two of those wanted to spread to others
after they left my house i hugged two
others who tested positive later
um i'm not planning to take the
astrazeneca vaccine my innate immunity
seems to be good
i will take ivermectin as precaution i'm
fairly active also
10 kilometers walking plus 45 minutes
boxing daily
um so yeah i think all of that
looks like good good analysis yeah good
analysis and
you know again i want i want a huge
effort put into figuring out exactly how
good ivermectin is what its limits are
what the minimum amount necessary is but
the
i from what i have seen i think there's
every reason to believe you are
better protected with ivermectin than
you are with the vaccines
right so in light of that given that you
seem to have innate immunity maybe you
just got lucky a bunch of times
yep that's certainly possible but
whether or not you have great innate
immunity
ivermectin appears to be highly
protective at very very low risk
and um that's probably all you can ask
we don't have anything better that
that's what's clear okay i'm just going
to grab a couple more i'm going to find
one more question
start scrolling down grab a couple more
comments first indiana weinstein and
heather croft i see
and can you make a clip of how they're
using the graphs um with regard to the
effect of iberomectin
yeah i think we should do that in the
description
um oh yes well the the
the powerpoint um that i was showing uh
will be linked to in the description
as well at least of the main one three
cheers for the bees
all right um
thanks so much for answering my question
at the top with regard to flccc evidence
i was mainly hoping to have a source to
argue and defend
for the ivermectin but i understand your
position i'm a big fan love your work
and
[Music]
how about let's end on god there's so
many
um
so many if you had recovered from covet
19 last april
april listen to where it is no i think
it's getting it's getting late
um if you had recovered from cover 19
last april would you prophylactically
dose with ivermectin or trust your
natural immunity
especially if someone closed tested
positive it's a really good question and
that actually raises
i have been asked um privately a couple
of times recently like wait a minute i'm
confused
i recently went back and watched your
very first episode in which you heather
said
described something that you and zach
had had in february of 2020
that you really thought might be coveted
um and uh we haven't we haven't returned
to it so let me just say
briefly um that
as much as what both zach and i
experienced
in february of 2020 seemed a perfect
match for what was then being described
as kovid
and and was totally unlike anything that
either of us had ever experienced before
like
waking up feeling asphyxiated unable to
stand up like i actually fell down
and just a hacking cough that would not
stop
um the most
reliable it seems symptom of covert that
wasn't being talked about then
yet which is loss of taste and smell uh
was not a feature for either of us
and all of us got tested
relatively early but we're not sure
about the reliability of those tests
um but we all came back negative and um
brett and i have since been
um tested as well and it just keeps
coming back negative for
yeah for um for prior infection um so
um i think it's i think it's not likely
at this point um
i think it's that zach and i had it
although it seemed at the time like oh
actually that's that's a perfect fit
wait before we go there i just want to
say
the evidence is particularly strong
because
against us against you having had it
yeah because
the evidence that you had the same thing
as each other is very good
yes right so the point is any individual
could have coveted and not lose their
sense of smell but the chances are much
lower that you'd have two people who had
coveted and neither of them lose their
sense of smell
the chances of somebody not showing up
as positive on a
have you ever had coveted test is high
enough but the chance that two people
wouldn't show up as positive or having
been positive
is much lower and then that one person
would show up as never having had it
on i think it's like three different
three different tests right so
combined i think you had something bad
something flu-like
and you know as bad as you've had but it
wasn't co but it was also very early
i can't remember the dates of your yeah
but i had just been in la
so that the timing actually the timing
was impossible like
i i picked something up like in the
rental car and the plane in l.a timing
was possible but the point is the timing
does not point to
it wasn't i think the timing actually
worked
we can debate that yeah but but i but i
don't think but anyway
i think the question that you've asked
let's put that part aside um
if if someone and presumably this person
is asking on behalf of someone that they
actually know or
are right if you would recover from
covert 19 last april would you
prophylactically dose with ivermectin
or trust your natural immunity
especially if someone close tested
positive
so let's take that's two different
questions so hold on the they have asked
the question
as what would we do and that is the way
we are going to answer it
right this is not advice for you this is
what we would do
in that hypothetical circumstance i've
got my answer you've got yours
yeah i do okay i'll start
my answer is i would not
prophylactically dose
but i would have it on hand and the very
first sign of symptoms i wouldn't
hesitate
as far as if somebody tested positive
who was close to you like somebody in
your house
i might consider then taking it the cost
of ivermectin
is low uh the risk and the
burden on the system is low but if
you've had covid
you're pretty well immune right
so this is going to be shocking to you
but that's exactly the answer that i had
arrived at
with i don't think this is a difference
i think just adding one level of
precision here which is that last april
is getting to the outside of that window
um that
maybe you're losing your immunity at
that point yeah
um so it would be it would be great to
get an antibody test for instance
um to to see if you actually are tighter
yeah for your tighter
um and i would say
depending on what if someone closed
tested positive means if it's someone
you're sharing a home with
and it's 14 months ago that you tested
positive
i think that i would prophylactically
dose with ivermectin for
the time period you know for a month or
so
um but that otherwise i think i wouldn't
because your natural immunity should do
it yeah but i would
definitely have it on hand all right and
i'm going to add one nuance here too and
then i'm going to add another one
i don't know what it is yet yeah we'll
find out yeah that's exciting
um no i would say if you were in a city
in which a new variant was spreading
then
the sense that you are immune from a
previous
uh encounter with covid is much less
secure
and then i would just dose with
ivermectin yeah yeah good
i don't have anything to add all right
which i think i think
this is it i think we're done all right
i think we're done um so
we probably won't come back before next
saturday because
um it's the last week of school for one
of our boys and we got um you've got
uh another podcast i don't think you're
going to be doing it live stream but
maybe
actually another person in the studio
right we got another person coming here
this week for um a cool cool podcast
um yeah so
join us at our patreons uh subscribe and
like to both this channel and the clips
channel check out our book website and
consider
consider uh doing an early purchase on
that that would be awesome
um what else
i can't think of any of the other
logistics things so i will say
um love the ones with whom you live and
eat good food and get outside
and if you encounter somebody playing
the bubble game steal their shoes
[Music]
[Music]
you